welcome to this video its Yardbird of
course let's see he's going T for it's
not happening so often against up I
tried come on I want to try something
else trying the Queens gambit accepted
if he was 44 it's not a given but
usually just play the main lines down
the slide that's a good choice for him
because I haven't looked at this line at
all and i recently lost a pretty drastic
game there get someone here on the under
eyes you see and i haven't we haven't
looked at this afterwards ah come on
let's force him but should be 296
something like that yeah I think 96 how
they play it
it was something with Queenie for some
something like that Queen d5 Queen G for
a b5 this is this kind of stuff ah come
on do i get this a gun no one okay now i
can take on b5 I think don't see what's
wrong with that or is it induces lots of
time actually maybe just develop come on
I have a pull-up at this moment my porn
habits is wrong but it's um it's no
problem i let them take on a success
what I'm trying to say should I go age
six year I'm kind of worried that he
plays Knight to g5 or this probably have
to move that anyway for night before
yeah that's it that's probably a decent
idea so night before here right
activating this night okay no I like my
position that that cannot be really bad
for black
where I can take and go night see to
write for c5 i cannot i cannot be cannot
be in ER i cannot have a disadvantage
see I don't believe it mmm I can also
take on d4 here maybe no no I cannot but
it's close it's really close Quincy 8
feels very passive I don't like that I
happen but maybe I mean what does this
what what what does this was sorry what
is he supposed to do here you can take
on see forward cannot cannot be that
brilliant I can take III and c5 is got
d5 this might be might be something
maybe yeah maybe otherwise c5 would be
really great but he can go d5
and so r up the aid maybe just just a
prep movie ax and group d 1 so c 5 d 5
ok now i can take and go Bishop g5 at
least that's an idea
c 5 g 5 e takes on that that's really a
little bit worse for me I guess we'll
yes loved worse
yeah pradnya Scott Bishop Bishop g5 can
probably just picking f2 or something
hmm not so easy we're just staying here
this Queen desegregate I don't know how
to play at least I don't have that clear
ideas him rattling okay eight which she
ignores I mean entirely hey blame work
why is why can you ignore that does he
have some tactical t5 tricks or what
yeah of course now you're getting your
tricks in and it works by a miracle or
what amazing
takes Knight takes bishop back or
anything okay come on let's do this
Knight takes a go Bishop c5 Scott Quincy
seven okay I'm going back
queen bee three maybe maybe that was
better
my eye it's two points it's a bit much
probably it's not super easy to play I
think forever I am still should have
gone rubes hookah c8 but I don't know
tending this
OC covering Roxy's 2301 sin not covering
III rocket III I think FG five that's
not going to work so check
ya can check check in tonight have
success or simpler but this also Winston
I guess check black it's on camera it
doesn't choose the simple win yeah a bit
a bit frustrating i think i just had a
good position at least it was ok so
there's this i can really not believe
but it's a matter of being very precise
i guess yeah I didn't like Quincy 8 and
it probably turns out to be a mistake so
this is what the engine is giving I
still don't quite get it by wow maybe I
can take III even yeah i was thinking
while he covers it somehow but how I
mean this is not really a great move as
he 5 is strong and it's in fact pretty
much winning so what didn't I do this
why didn't they play the move especially
considering that I had a bad feeling
about Quincy aid I mean I didn't like it
but I felt it so should be somewhat okay
so after this this this how is he
playing the engine wants to play 91
which is kind of a clear sign that white
is in trouble then just this
possibly this move here I'm just okay I
mean me engine gets blackout upon and
now I really my problem was I will
always wanted to take and go see five
but sorry but after d5 this is very
awkward I'm just not well coordinated
here I'm not not in a position to take
this kind of thing it really doesn't
matter that his structure has ruined the
the piece activity here is a problem
real problem this is why I tried this
and now this move he went here Queen D 7
i'm sure before yeah i mean he clearly
blundered the Queen iya that wasn't
intended yeah he just blundered the
queen but he had them he had he had this
d5 resource which kept him in the game
ed 595 and 25 he resides self while I'm
such an idiot oh yeah ok
I was anyway okay and now I don't really
get any activity I queen bee three was
bad i have I immediately saw that but I
only have 20 something seconds left it
was a bit more testing but white is two
pawns up it's never going to be enough
well that's clearly better than than
this check no just just struggling here
this is pretty cute by the way from the
fleet's a nice move couldn't could have
done that but you didn't would if it
would have been nice okay well thanks
for watching